barry cullen sales manager for a duck
farm is making his daily rounds as a
native of Northern Ireland he's feeling
a bit concerned these days he's worried
that if Britain were to leave the EU it
could have negative consequences for the
farm which lies right on the border
between Northern Ireland and the
Republic of Ireland the farm might end
up having to pay customs on meat exports
to the north should Britain leave the EU
the border to the single market would
run right through County Monaghan the
road signs change from miles per hour to
kilometers per hour so that's how close
we are to that the border the border
also symbolizes an age-old conflict
marking the edge of the United Kingdom
for Protestants and dividing an island
that many Catholics see as one nation
the EU has been a decisive factor in
keeping the peace on both sides of the
border for two decades now you could set
the the political landscape in Northern
Ireland bike you know 15-20 years to
what it was like whenever the the
British Army was in the north and when
you were travelling anywhere you would
always have to be stopped your car you'd
have to get out you know
searches we were always searched and so
a lot of it wasn't a very nice time huge
police stations like this one in the
border village of cross Moglen a
Catholic stronghold in Northern Ireland
or former customs posts are relics of
that era before the peace process the
inner Irish border was among the most
closely monitored in Europe says Anthony
Suarez so a lorry driver passing from
the Republic of Ireland coming into
Northern Ireland
at this building the lorry driver would
have have to enter this building with
his all the documentation declaring what
he had on board his lorry later the
British authorities converted the
customs post to checkpoints in the 1970s
and 80s many of the smaller crossing
points were demolished and the border
fortified British forces kept an eye out
for terrorists at the official border
crossings Irish farmer Hugh Conway would
not like to see that situation returned
he sees today's open border as a huge
step forward he even remembers the
frequent smuggling that went on here
during World War two the police wouldn't
watch you for small things let you go
small things when you had nothing it
used to be difficult for the farmers in
the south to do business with the north
Hugh Conway's farm was right behind a
closed border crossing we couldn't take
cattle just through that room you had a
second way back to the safe and these
priests had extended cattle we're with
our Maher and Killian the Northern Irish
farmers wouldn't like to see a return to
the old days either Keith and Alan
Wilson are cattle breeders Protestants
and optimists the elder Wilson can still
remember the customs duties but they
hope that any reintroduction of border
checks would have only economic and not
political consequences for Northern
Ireland if it didn't happen to me that
they would leave it I don't think it'll
affect the peace process I think it's
going far enough now for - for the sound
of his own fate Northern Ireland's
largest Protestant party backs a brexit
and says farmers shouldn't worry about
leaving the EU most Catholics on the
other hand like berry oppose leaving the
EU
Barry Cullen may enjoy a tight horse
race but not close political ones he's
worried that the great majority of
voters in Britain simply don't
understand what's actually at stake if I
was betting I would say that they'll
stay in but a very low odds bet I think
even 50/50 Barry is voting YES in the
referendum and he hopes that in future
he will still be able to enjoy his quick
trips across the border to bet on the
horses with the Pope